How can we create online programs
that maybe aren't for full degrees
but there's still a skills base,
potentially certifications
that have the branding
that are recognized by employers.
There needs to be a shift
on the employer side
to accept these new types of trainings.
Tess Manning, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Good morning to you.
Good evening to me.
How are you?
Thanks, Michael. I'm doing well.
Great to be here.
Appreciate the invitation.
I'm very, very happy that you're here
because we're going to talk about
one of my favorite markets and industries
that unfortunately,
I don't know nearly enough
as much as I should,
which is the education space.
And you have a really
fascinating trajectory
all the way from working at a company
like Pluralsight, which I have used
and many of my friends use
all the way to now
being a principal at the GSV Ventures
and really focusing
on the education sector more deeply.
But in between,
there were some other
really incredible things.
Like doing an MBA at Stanford,
helping teach classes at Stanford.
And we have to get started
with your fun fact,
which is the fact that, you know,
your a dancer at heart
and you actually taught some hip hop
and dance to some people at Stanford
and in the VC space.
That's right.
So, while I was at GSV,
I was teaching, a what turned into
a weekly hip hop dance class
with one of my classmates
to all of our classmates
starting our first year.
We have it at the end of the year
musical that is essentially
a parody of the GSP.
And we rope in a lot of people
to perform that year.
A lot of women and men
who had never danced before found out
they had love and passion for dance
in their late 20s, early 30s,
because I was really inspired by that.
And so, my classmate and I
started actually teaching around the bay.
And I think my favorite story
is that Heidi Roizen
at Threshold Ventures came to class,
found out what we were doing,
and she organized
a group of women and a few men.
And we taught them
a full three minute dance
over the course of eight weeks
and had a final performance
at the threshold office.
Which was incredible.
Unbelievable.
So, Tess, walk me a little bit
through your journey.
Why education?
Why Stanford MBA?
What's going on over there?
Yes. It's been an interesting journey.
So, I started my startup journey
in New York.
I had worked at a number of startups
over the course of seven years
before moving to
out to the West Coast for GSV.
The first startup I actually worked at
was during college.
I was an intern
at one of the first companies
that was part of the first cohort
of TechStars in New York,
and they were an education
technology company.
And this was back in 2011.
And their vision was
to democratize access
to your knowledge on the web
and to help people learn,
adult learners learn new topics
in a fun way.
That really resonated with me
because I was really passionate about
economic development
and helping people all over the world
find opportunities,
which I think a lot of people
have a similar mission
when they're in college.
But this really felt
like a viable way to do that.
So, I was really excited about
the power of technology
and in spreading education.
I had a few different companies
that I worked at before coming back
full circle to ed tech.
I had worked at two other startups
in New York that were both fast growth,
learned kind of the ins and outs
of lots of different functions
from sales and account management
to product, people operations,
recruiting, really the full gamut,
aside from actually
programming and designing
and fell in love with working
with early stage startups.
So, right before I came to the GSV,
I worked at a startup called Andela,
which at the time
was a tiny talent accelerator focused on
high potential young people in Nigeria.
And we were giving them
six months of full stack training
for free
and then helping place them
with long term roles
as distributed engineers.
Really inspiring,
life changing for them, for us,
for the teams that they worked with
all over the world.
Really demonstrated
the power of diverse teams
and it was just an incredible
win-win all around
and commercially viable as well.
So, that startup now, you know,
there are over 2,000 engineers,
in series company, really incredible.
And so I was excited
about that business model.
So, coming to the GSV,
I knew I wanted to stay in ed tech
and workforce development.
So, my summer at Pluralsight,
right after that IPO-ed.
And then coming out of the GSV,
I had to make that decision
of going back to an early stage company,
or as fate will have it,
found out that GSV Ventures,
which is an ed tech venture fund
that focuses on early stage founders,
was hiring in tandem
with growing their second fund.
And so, the stars kind of aligned
and turns out Andela and Pluralsight
were both GSV portfolio companies
and it felt like the right next step.
So, I've been here for about a year now.
That's remarkable.
First of all, it sounds like
over the course of your career,
I mean, it's a formal career
as you summarize it.
So, it's huge and impressive but
you know, it sounds like in retrospect,
it's pretty easy to draw the dots
and to see this linear curve.
But was it a linear career?
Did you imagine when
you were in Africa
that you're going to be in Pluralsights
to the GSB, to GSV?
What was going on there?
No. Absolutely not.
I mean, it's hilarious.
When I look at the resumes
of all my classmates at the GSB
and compare them with mine,
you know that,
so many of them have stories
that they were making
kind of very conscious,
calculated decisions
every step of the way,
and then they got to GSB
and were like,
oh, my God, what now.
So, I've always been a bit like,
oh my God, what now?
And then once I got to GSB,
I actually had more clarity
when I was here
on what I wanted to do.
So coming in, I mean,
I might have been one of the only people
that stuck to what I wrote in my essay.
I wrote that I wanted
to help education technology companies
find viable business models.
Because historically,
it's been very difficult. Right?
And you can even see that
on the funding landscape,
on the number of public companies
in ed tech,
the number of growth companies,
and that's all changing
especially this year, right,
which is great.
But at the time, that was something
I really wanted to focus on
and what I did coming at the other end.
But getting there,
yes, like crazy journey.
I worked at a marketing software startup,
I worked at Timehop,
the social media nostalgia app.
Were it's like,
all over the place really,
and all kinds of functions.
But, you know,
I think every step along the way,
I knew it deep in my knowledge
that I wanted to remain in tech.
I love working closely with engineers
and building products
and with early stage founders.
So, it was really concrete
in that area.
And then as time went on,
I realized that I was most inspired
by working at a company
with a strong mission.
And so, the decision, for instance,
to work at Pluralsight,
was part of that.
I wanted to become
more of a sector expert.
I wanted to understand
what it was like
at a later stage company
in the tech sector
and how the businesses differ there.
So, sort of, longer than that
but that's the gist of it in a way.
I have to learn a little bit about
the education sector
in order to really grasp
what you're doing in the GSV
and where your passion lies.
Because it sounds like
you fell in love with ed tech.
And with finding a balance between
the right business model
to a high impact opportunity
to really help people, obviously,
through your experience with Africa.
But it sounds like it's deeper than that.
Talk to me a little bit about this
dissonance between finding
a good business model for a high impact
or social good company.
Sure.
So, to take a step back,
looking at this problem
through the lens of how
we make investments at GSV,
first and foremost,
we always say that
the greatest returns on the fund
will come from the companies
with the greatest impact
and return on education. Right?
And so, these are the companies
that are going to reach
the largest number of learners
or they will be lowering
the cost of education, right,
resulting in being able
to access more learners.
And they're having their strong efficacy
with whatever product
or service that they're offering.
So, improves outcomes for education.
So, we're looking at companies
through those lens
when we're making a decision
on whether or not we'll invest in them.
So, what that ends up
when you're looking
at very, very early stage companies
and trying to decide
what's going to last,
what's going to be a sustainable model,
what will do all of those things
or a combination of them
is something that, you know, the models
have changed a lot in ed tech.
So, I think in the early days in K-12,
there are a lot of companies
that were trying
to sell directly to schools.
Fast forward today,
you see a lot of different
creative models where someone like,
you know, a class dojo is free
for a number of years and built up
this enormous base of teachers
that were absolutely obsessed
with their product
and it was their lifeblood
for communication
outside of the classroom
with parents and students.
And then they flipped
on monetization last year.
And then, you know,
so, that's more
of a direct to consumer model in a way,
even though it's in the classroom.
And so they don't have to worry about
these really long institutional
school sales cycles
where there's only a limited number
of essentially government dollars
that they're fighting over.
So, companies of today
in ed tech and on K-12
and higher ed, for instance,
are trying to come up
with more creative models.
And things like Course Hero,
for instance,
is a Chegg competitor and they are
a marketplace to student resources.
So, once again,
going straight to the learner
versus going and creating
a university partnership.
On the enterprise learning side,
there is something I believe
in for a long time
that adult learners,
that cost of learning, yes,
there is always going to be
an individual cost as life goes on.
But the reality of today is that
we are all going to need
to become lifelong learners.
Whether you understand that now or not,
we're going to constantly
need new skills,
we are going to constantly
be changing jobs.
And probably, working longer
than any other moment in history.
And so, I would like to see in
and there is a belief
and understanding now
that companies should take on
a lot of that cost
of retraining their employees
over time as well.
So, there are a lot
of business models now
focused on having the company pay
for their employees education.
Whether that's in-house,
because they're going to stay
or like a Pluralsight, for instance,
or Coursera, or it could be someone
like Guild Education that's paying
for their front line workers
to earn college degrees
or skill certificates,
which is pretty incredible.
And those employees,
they know will be leaving.
Yeah. So, a few thoughts there.
I just had a fascinating class
at the Graduate School of Engineering
a Product Management class
were actually we were working with Target
and I was the only
Stanford student there.
We had somebody from Amazon,
from Microsoft, from Google.
And because they were coming in
for external training to do
to shift their priorities
within the company,
that I believe some of them
were moving from engineering
to product management.
And all of a sudden,
I find myself working
with people that are 10, 15 years older.
They have all sorts
of different experiences
and that combined learning.
I think obviously, I'm getting much more
excited and emotional
when I think of companies
that are doing it
for the frontline workers
to get college degrees
and something like that.
But it really looks like
the world is changing
to what you were saying.
What are some bigger problems
that we are still thinking of today
in terms of education,
whether it's accessibility,
it's information dissemination.
What are some of those big picture things
that we still haven't figured out?
Yeah. Great question.
Also, love that story.
I think that another thing,
just as a quick aside,
that I think will be huge
is how do we bring together learners
of different ages.
And when you think about adult learning,
age has been such a construct in the past.
And really, like a lot of companies,
are experimenting with adult learning
by creating cohorts
of different age learners.
So, I love that idea.
So, the, sorry,
I just lost track of the question now.
The bigger question. Yes.
It's because you're so passionate
about these ideas.
Or just you know, rambling on.
So, a couple of things, though.
I mean, when you look at the US,
for instance, our levels of literacy
and numeracy for college graduates
have not been improving
over the last, like 25 years.
The actual graduation
levels have been improving. Right?
And so, there's been
a huge focus in the US
over the past few, let's say,
presidencies
to increase graduation rates or not.
About 88% national level.
But there are, you know,
the actual outcomes
of high school education are not there.
So, when you're thinking about
what problems need to be solved,
that's an enormous one
is the actual efficacy of education
and outcomes there.
It's really hard to change the curriculum
and to change the system.
But the US education levels
are falling behind
many other countries in the world.
And so, if we're thinking about
something domestic,
that's definitely a huge issue.
And then, of course,
that problem applies to any potentially
like emerging country as well.
We're used to having
an enormous number of learners
and so, you are obviously not
going to have
the right number of teachers
that are able to see drive
those outcomes either potentially.
So, that's a big one for sure.
The other one in higher education,
we're going to be
over doubling the number
of college age students
in the next 10 to 15 years.
And there just aren't enough
institutions in the world
that have the capacity to educate
the number of college age students.
That's an enormous problem.
By the way, why is that happening?
The world population growth.
They're just going to be
an enormous number of people
of that age level.
And so, in terms of traditional
institutions, you know,
you can't spend up a college overnight.
You can't, you know,
when you think about things
like accreditation,
which is a huge obstacle
in higher ed innovation in the US
so, making sure that students
are getting credit
for the courses that they're taking,
you know, a ton of hurdles there.
It is an archaic system
that stifles a lot of innovation.
But then, you know,
and then internationally, same issue.
So, one thing that we need to deal with
and think ahead
for which companies like Coursera
and others are doing is
how can we create online programs
that maybe aren't for full degrees,
but there's still a skills base,
potentially certifications
that have the branding
that are recognized by employers.
There needs to be a shift
from the employer side
to accept these new types of trainings.
And we need to find a way to educate
that group of college,
"traditionally college age learners"
coming down the road.
And then the enterprise,
I think I've mentioned it already.
But just thinking about
how do you map the skills
within your organization,
understand the gaps
and then help up and up and reskill,
which is there's a lot,
a lot of like hot conversation
around right now
and everyone knows
they need to do it.
But actually figuring it out
is very difficult.
Especially in roles that aren't,
you know,
that have more of an emphasis
on soft skills
or things that are historically
hard to measure.
It's tough to figure out
how to handle those.
Tess, I have to say that,
you know, I've done quite
a few of these episodes.
One of the things that inspires me most
across these episodes
is when I meet people
that are just truly passionate
and curious about what they're doing.
That their positions there
and it's not just because
it was a cool opportunity
and just a nice jumpstart.
But really,
they're following this trajectory
of following their passion,
following their curiosity.
It's something that I live by
and that I've become
more and more inspired through this show
that the people that are really making
a difference are those that
they are truly following their passions.
And things don't become easy,
but they become doable
and they become energized.
And I'm learning so much
just from this
short 20 minute conversation.
Tell me a little bit about
the Girl Develop It.
You are on the advisory board there.
What are you doing over there
and what is sort of the mission?
Because it sounds really phenomenal.
Yes, Girl Developer It
is a nonprofit that's been around
for a long time now,
almost 10 years.
And they've reached over
100,000 adult learners,
primarily women.
They provide free
or low cost introductory level courses
in programming topics,
and they've expanded a bit more
to things like digital marketing
and a few others.
But it's really incredible.
I mean, the goal is
to create an environment
where adult learners,
it was intended originally for women,
but it's really open to anyone,
can learn in a judgment free space.
You know, If they have been stuck in
and maybe just a pretty average role
for the last 10, 15, 20 years.
Maybe they have a degree,
maybe they don't.
I mean, really,
we have learners of all ages.
They can come to Girl Development.
They can say, I'm curious about
unity development,
I'm curious about dev ops,
I'm curious about JavaScript,
Maybe I heard about it on a podcast,
maybe I heard about it from a friend,
but I have no idea where to even start.
I'm embarrassed.
I don't even know the right
questions to ask.
And they can come and take a course
and then start to create
a new career trajectory from there.
So, really incredible.
There are volunteer instructors
who are also paid
time for teaching the classes.
And yeah, it's really just an amazing,
amazing non-profit
and it's really fun story
how I got involved.
I met an entrepreneur named Brenda Jin
in January last year.
So, we've only known each other
or about a year.
It wasn't the right fit
for an investment,
but her and I really hit it off
and have become
kind of thought partners and friends.
And so, she asked me
to get involved this summer.
And it's been a blast.
We had a mini conference.
We got Unity involved,
the teacher in course sponsor it.
And Unity's a partner of GSVs.
So, it's just amazing to see
how the education ecosystem,
everybody really plays together
and supports one another.
Tess, it sounds phenomenal.
I thank you for all the work
that you're doing, both with the GSV,
but also on these advisory roles.
And for teaching dance.
I'm still owe to take,
to take the social dance class
that I'm supposed to.
One day, hopefully I would get in touch
with Philly as well at the GSV.
But for now
I'll do the social dance class.
Tess, three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
And thank you for being
so generous with your time here.
Sure, great question.
This is very difficult.
So, I mean, I think that two
the two more obvious ones, if you will,
I would say, number one is optimistic.
That's just for better or for worse,
part of my DNA.
Yeah. I think that's anyone that's working
in an early stage startup,
anyone that's just constantly
trying new things
like you kind of have to be
and you want to see things come to life.
And yes, that's a big one.
And then, I hear this one a lot.
So, I guess I could say it's
maybe not self described,
but energetic.
So, really, like, I try to bring energy
to everything I do.
But it's true.
It's something I realized over time,
and the longer and longer
you're in the workforce
and then, you know,
maybe increasingly difficult roles
or more responsibility, etc.
like the energy you put out
into the world
is how you're going to see
that's going to reflect on others
and really kind of change the mood
of a team you're working on.
And endure oneself,
that's something I focus on a lot.
And then, I guess the last one
would be maybe somewhere around,
so, I used to also teach kids
creative movement in shelters
in New York for nine years
of another nonprofit.
So, dance,
but it's more creative movement.
And I kind of love this idea,
of not just exactly creativity,
but something around
like creativity, fluidity, where,
you know, no matter what's coming at you,
you're able to
kind of make something out of it
and feel something from it, adapt,
like something along the lines of that.
And so, maybe it's more of a,
like a dance move.
You're like living with a dance move.
Some concepts around there.
I love that.
I attribute a lot of my optimism
and my, you know,
the fact that I am energized
whenever something changes
or whenever I'm tackling a challenge
to the fact that I participated in a lot
of high school musicals
when I was back in high school.
That was one of my favorite hobbies.
Because it was all about
interchanging ideas.
And then, you know,
and then, the bridge would fall
from the stage,
because somebody pushed it by accident
then you have to now respond to it
and have fun with it.
Exactly.
So, I attribute a lot of that to that.
Tess, Thank you so, so much.
This was wonderful.
Thank you for the Inspiration.
It was great.
Thank you Michael.
That's awesome.
And one day we'll put together
a musical in our staff together.
100%.